the end of the day humanity has more
that brings them together than separates
them right and what is that
the parents love their kids they want
their kids to go to school
they want health care they want a decent
job they don't want a food basket
they want some autonomy and dignity and
hope for their lives i mean
most of humanity has very similar ideals
and that was what i was able to draw on
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leomi tech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
today we're going to the us government
and we're going to be meeting dave
hardin maryland's first democratic
candidate for congress
dave is the managing director of the
georgetown strategy group a washington
dc next generation firm that leverages
talent
technology and capital to help solve
some of the world's most complex
problems
in may of 2019 president trump awarded
mr hardin the presidential award for
distinguished service
the highest award in the foreign service
for sustained extraordinary
accomplishment in the conduct of the
foreign policy
he led a bureau focused on global crisis
response and political transition
with an annual budget of 4.8 billion
dollars
and a staff of nearly 1200 people he
also spearheaded all usaid efforts to
respond to global crises
and stabilization efforts including
responses in haiti
iraq somalia south sudan syria the west
bank and gaza
and yemen dave hardin welcome to 20
minute leaders i'm so happy that you're
here how are you
i'm great it's happy that i'm i'm happy
to be here with you too
and you're all grown up now i remember
when you were in middle school and now
look at you you're all grown up and
living at stanford and being a big shot
i used to have
math competitions with your son ryan all
throughout middle school and
he's one of the big reasons why i i
started loving math and so
it was a you know i i love your family
and
you know the work that you're doing has
always fascinated me and it's really far
from the things that i get to do
in my day-to-day so i'm excited to dig
deeper into you know your journey over
these next 20 minutes whether it's in
the government and usaid and
and the incredible things that you've
been doing in the middle east a lot of
responsibility and some incredible
incredible situations
but also you know a little bit in the
tech scene and running for congress i
don't think i ever got to talk to
somebody who's
running for congress dave i'm not going
to do more justice by
by iterating on the biography but i want
you to take me throughout
your journey and the big milestones
things that really shaped
you as a leader in your own domain what
are some of those experiences
that now you're reflecting back and
saying wow those were incredible
so you know the funny thing is i
grew up on a small farm in rural america
and i would have been perfectly happy
being a lawyer in a small town
uh but when i was 16 we had an exchange
student from switzerland came
he came and lived with us and it was you
know in many ways it was exciting and
interesting and difficult because
you know back in that age uh you know in
the 70s
in rural america having a swiss student
live in your house and go to your high
school
it was a very unusual thing but it
opened my eyes to the world
and ultimately after college i joined
the peace corps
and i flew to botswana and i started a
a a junior high school and
it was a mat i was a english teacher a
sports teacher and i raised chickens
and it was really an extraordinary
experience being in africa in the mid
80s and from there on
i kind of i kind of seized a big world
life and
adventure you know from from botswana to
south asia
to central asia and then many many many
years in the middle east
wow and so you know as you join the
government and you're in the middle east
you're
putting yourself really in places that i
can't imagine they're in the comfort
zone of
growing up in a small place in the in
the united states
why why join them the government and and
take on leadership positions in the way
that you did
so there were many reasons i mean first
of all i loved representing america i
represent kind of the
city on the hill that's shining city on
the hill the big
vision of america uh and not only was it
the big vision of america but it was the
generous part right
and we can debate american foreign
policy um all
we want but i think you know in my view
since world war ii
we've been an overwhelming force for
good and so i was i was really happy
and pleased and honored to represent the
united states
but i also you know i went in when
everybody else was leaving so if there
was a
war whether it was in libya or iraq or
in yemen
or the conflict between the israelis and
the palestinians particularly in gaza
i went in and i had the resources and
the teams and the capabilities
to mitigate the risks to reduce conflict
and to
um you know basically to alleviate human
suffering and so for me
that was an extraordinary mission that i
was able to drive for more than two
decades
and so as you're in these very very
difficult places dealing with some of
the most incredible
uh conflicts uh especially you know the
the is the middle east conflict between
the israelis and palestinians working
with gaza
as part of usaid what what did you learn
from that experience what was it like
dealing
you know coming in from the united
states and seeing seeing this big
conflict
and but also from a very humanitarian
perspective and at the end seeing the
the humans down the line on both ends
and trying to mitigate risks and
and help save lives yeah so i i mean
i do want to talk about the
israeli-palestinian element of this but
i also worked in lebanon
i did a lot on on syria and the syrian
war and i did a lot
in yemen including cross-border issues
that related to yemen
and saudi arabia or the gulf and you
know look i think at the end of the day
humanity has more that brings them
together than separates them
right and what is that the parents love
their kids
they want their kids to go to school
they want health care they want a decent
job
they don't want a food basket they want
some autonomy and dignity
and hope for their lives i mean most of
humanity
has very similar ideals and that was
what i was able to draw on
the other thing that i was able to draw
on i think
look getting involved in the
israeli-palestinian conflict
is the death knell in a bureaucracy
and for a political career right you end
up getting killed
and so what i was able to do is not take
a side i was able to just call balls and
strikes
a good american term right you know i
just saw it as i saw
i saw it and i reacted the way i i
understood the facts and i worked with
everybody
i worked with everybody and i really
tried to find that common ground
um and to be honest you know most of us
had similar ideas on what should be
and when you focused on that commonality
of our humanity it was easier to drive
results
very very cool now 20 minutes is not a
long time and i have to talk about
something that i
perhaps i'll never get to experience and
definitely a lot of the people watching
this
it's sort of like we in you know in
coding we call this a black box
something that just
works and and we have no idea how it
works because it's so complicated
you're deciding to run for congress
yeah what is that how does that
that's a good question i don't know i'm
gonna find out all right
so here's literally what happened so i i
was a
you know senior foreign service officer
um
for 20 years i was you know towards the
end of my career
obama had put me up as uh the assistant
administrator for all complex
emergencies in the entire world
and i was confirmed by the by the
democrats and the republicans right
and then when trump came in i still
stayed on and i responded
to the yemen conflict uh and trump gave
me the biggest award
in the foreign service but in 2018 i
quit
i opened up my own firm the georgetown
strategy group
and i was happy to be an entrepreneur
doing a lot of the same things that i
had been doing my entire life
but this time in the private sector
without a layer of bureaucracy over top
of me
um and and by the way you know i one of
the companies that i ran
had israeli american investors and
palestinians
in ramallah who are my software
engineers and so i was
i it was great i mean uh being an
entrepreneur was
absolutely fantastic but
on january 6th
we were here i was at the farm uh my
wife was in dc
and i heard uh the attack on
the capitol building and i was extremely
worried for her
um and i was extremely worried for
america
but even more so ryan your classmate
your friend
uh was deployed overseas at that time
and he was in cutter
at led base and his uh his job then
was to keep eyes on america's
adversaries right the taliban
and isis uh the russians the iranians
and he was protecting the homeland
and he calls up and he says dad that i
can't do my job
because it looks like america's in the
middle of a civil war
it looks like there's chaos at home and
you know it was one thing when i
traveled overseas it was another thing
when my son was overseas
and that insurrection was fueled in part
by andy harris the guy that i'm running
against in maryland's first district
you think of maryland and you think of
you know basically a moderate state
that like makes reasonable decisions but
andy harris decided
to um to not certify the electoral
college
he brought a gun into the capitol that
day he got in a fight in the capitol
that night
he failed to honor the capitol police
that protected everybody's lives
and i thought to myself i have worked
all over the world fighting for
democracy
i have worked all over the world
connecting people that have been
disconnected from economies
and bringing them into the fold and i
can't
care about everybody in the world
regardless of language
tribe ethnicity religion
race all of that i can't care about the
entire world
and not care about my people and i and
as i said i grew up in rural america and
i
understood that it was time for me to
come home
it was for me it was time for me to
protect our democracy
and it was time for me to to use the
same economic skills
that i had learned overseas in 20 or 30
years of working overseas
and bringing economic opportunity home
to my people
and so on january 6 i decided to run for
for congress it takes a little while to
set it up
i officially launched on may 10th but
i'm all in i'm running for congress
unbelievable entrepreneur tell me
you're you're an entrepreneur right now
you were a tech entrepreneur
a little while ago but and now you're a
different kind of entrepreneur tell me
about the strategy you wake up okay it's
may 10th
it's go time you now have to win an
election you're running
for what sounds like a very very good
cause you're very very passionate about
it you have a good product that you're
offering you know in that in the tech
terms
how do you go to market now how do you
get people to understand who dave harden
is
and really really understand to a point
where they want you to represent them
so it's a really funny thing because
i could easily get on international
media
to talk about the middle east so like in
the last say three weeks i've been on
all the major media outlets
talking about the middle east but to
talk about my congressional run
you know in a little rural area of uh
of maryland is a lot harder to break
through in that media cycle
so um so you know when i do these big
uh let's say bbc i did bbc recently
right you know
tens of millions of people are listening
to bbc all over the world
there's probably three people in my
district who are listening to bbc
but they always begin by saying dave
harden you're running for congress but
you know tell us about the middle east
so um so you know i need to do a couple
things i need to get visibility
uh i need to get it i need to
nationalize this race
and to be quite honest when people when
people talk about the american political
system as being
broken and rigged it's kind of true
right i'm an outsider i'm a bit of an
insurgent even though i was in
government forever in the executive
rants
i was a nonpartisan i worked for whoever
was in power if it was a republican
president or a democratic president
i just served america and now i have to
take sides on a thousand different
issues
um i i have to kind of break through
the political elite structures at the
local level
uh you have to raise an enormous amount
of money in order to be credible and
viable
and you got to be able to do it all but
the thing is
having run america's responses to
some of the most complex crises of the
of
this century allowed me to build a team
that's fast and agile and responsive and
quick and so i feel very confident about
where we are in this election
and it really sounds like you're
approaching this election as some sort
of another
war or another conflict that you've
helped resolve around the world
again for the benefit of your of your
country for the benefit of democracy and
and how you see where things should go
and so
how do you keep yourself in check so you
know things are moving on a day-by-day
basis you launched exactly a month ago
from from what i understand
and and how do you how do you you know
sort of keep yourself in check and see
okay
are we improving what do we need to
improve how do we pivot because these
are really the questions that every
every entrepreneur is asking themselves
at least you know on my street here
so before i answer the question about
how i do it now i want to spend a moment
about how i used to do it and as you
know
i was the longest serving american
diplomat
in u.s history in israel right and so
how did i keep myself
focused and effective through many many
wars
when we lived in israel from 2006 to
2000 or sorry 2005 to 2016.
well what i did is i ran along the beach
from hersley to tel aviv to go to work
and that was a very long run but it was
an effective way for me to be able to
focus
and to get some rhythm and balance in my
life so
i um i'm a little bit older now
and i don't in some regards have a
little less time because tel aviv is so
laid back that you can easily do that
right but
but uh the east coast is a little less
laid back but i do try
to run and focus and i i run either
along the country roads
or when i'm in dc i run along the mall
and that helps me kind of think through
what i'm doing i also
don't sweat the details the small things
that much
it's it's it's easy to get caught up
in everything that goes wrong right and
and and look the details matter it's
true but at the end of the day that one
email or that one tweet or that one
you know that one speech it really
almost certainly won't have an
everlasting effect and so i think you
know to keep that in mind
uh and just to keep you know not having
uh perfection be the enemy of
of the good you know that's one that's
one other thing that i try to do
amazing take me a little bit higher now
30 000 feet in the air the landscape
you know you're what it sounds to me
like one of your goals is to make a
the biggest positive impact possible
does that work today
in in the political systems that work in
in the democracy is this really where
you know you can really make a strong
impact i'm asking as you know a young
entrepreneur where you know i see the
things that are happening in the tech
world how fast they're moving and and
i'm also saying you know the disruptions
that we've been experiencing you know
in israel we've been going through four
elections maybe five
hopefully not what's your take on that
i mean i definitely believe that
technology is uh
and capital are going to be drivers of
massive impact and i'll explain
in just a second but our political
system has to work as well
right and and you know from an american
perspective
if our democracy doesn't sustain itself
if the politics don't work then
everything else is going to fail
i mean i think our democracy is kind of
a foundational principle
of our society and our culture and our
economic and political
success and so it we must nurture our
democracy
the other thing from an economic
perspective that i'm a keenly aware of
is that climate change is going to have
massive
disruptive economic impact and it
doesn't
matter if one again where i live it
doesn't matter if you believe in climate
uh change or you are a climate and you
think climate change is a hoax
it doesn't matter because the the
capital markets
and the technology have already decided
we're moving to climate solutions and i
mean clearly
israel is at the very leading edge of
climate solutions
the question for america and the
question for my district
is will we innovate
design build and sell the climate
solutions to the world
right or or will we buy from those who
do
and so i would like to seize and own
that future i would like to create
the incubators the r d
firms uh the you know the the marriage
of public and private capital
uh to drive those
climate solutions and and part of the
reason why this is important to me
is that i know in baltimore where i i
grew up and is just outside of the
district in which i'm running
the steel industry collapsed in the late
70s and early 80s and when the steel
industry collapsed
it was massive massive catastrophic
failure
for households communities and and the
surrounding cities
that kind of disruption is happening
again right this is what climate will do
it will disrupt
energy agriculture infrastructure
um you name it it's going to be
there's going to be massive changes in
our economy and i don't want what
happened
in the late 70s and early 80s to happen
again i would like to learn
from that experience and to have the
united states be kind of the leading
innovator and thinker for climate
solutions for
for for generations to come i
love love that perspective and i want to
go back a second
sweating the small stuff i think that's
something that you know
as as i mature i'm learning the
importance of that and i think that
no matter no no matter what leadership
position you're in this is
a crucial element what is your secret
sauce so when you're
you know especially in a very emotional
moment where you're you know you're
running for congress this is a very
passionate thing that you know
requires a lot of emotional involvement
you see
you see these tweets and you see the
race and you see the incumbent that
you're obviously running against
how how do you as a person and as a
leader react to that in in a common
stable way well first of all i think
being a leader means that you set up
great teams
uh and that is one thing that i've been
able to do
whether it's in government or in the
private sector and so i i
have people that have been with me who
were i i took
many of the people that were in my
startup with me into my campaign
um and they're from all over the country
and they're all ages too by the way i
mean i have you know i
i don't hire a lot of 44 year olds
because they have mortgages and kids in
college right but i hired 24 year olds
and and 74 year olds and and that
actually has worked very very nicely so
a you want to set up
you want to set up good teams b
at least from where i sit
i've had a big life i've had an iconic
career
if i take a big swing and miss it
doesn't matter
right if at the end of the day i lose
i'm going to open up a farm brewery at
the farm and will be perfectly fine
uh and and i think it's also important
you know to put all this in some
perspective i mean i
served and i worked in south sudan and
in yemen
right or uh or the people that were
just suffering horribly in syria
and so when you see their lives and you
see the things that they're
they're grappling with you know when an
email that goes out that has a couple
typos in it that makes you look silly
and stupid
it's you're still alive and you're still
running for congress
i love that dave thank you so much for
for these insights and uh and you know
i'm excited to see where this goes and
and i just believe the passion that
you're exuding here i i believe
you know how much you love the country
and and you know doing this for
for the right reasons i think it's that
that's just really really cool so thank
you very much for coming and sharing
this with me i have a few more questions
not about congress not about your
professional journey and i want to take
you back a little bit to your childhood
what fascinated you as a kid perhaps the
subject in middle school or a passion
hobby
so here's a funny thing when i was a
young kid
i my dad said all right it's time for
you to go out there and earn your money
and uh he gave me he loaned me
uh 50 bucks
to go buy chickens and i bought chickens
and they delay
they laid eggs and then i sold eggs to
everybody in the neighborhood
uh and it was great i i sold um
uh for five cents less than what they
could buy them in the store although if
i were smarter i would have sold them
for
you know ten cents more but uh you know
i and i delivered them to their house
and it was farm fresh eggs
uh you know from the farm uh and i did
that for a long time
enough to uh buy a horse which then had
a horse
which then i then sold and bought a car
so that was my
childhood days yep it almost sounds like
tom sawyer
and then a role model somebody that
inspires you
or inspired you along your journey
either professionally or personally
all right well in uh in that age
baseball was everything and i was a big
little league player in baseball
and the orioles the baltimore baseball
team had
a uh a third baseman his name was brooks
robinson
and he's a hall of famer and he was
absolutely great
and i remember being able to meet with
him and have a
you know a 15-minute conversation about
baseball and life
and it was just an event for me that i
will never forget right this was
somebody who was
great and big and succeeded in
in all of his wildest dreams he came
from humble beginnings
and for me that that is something i'll
never forget
amazing and what are three more or less
words
that you would use to describe yourself
well i have enormous energy i bring uh
intense passion into the mix and i care
dave thank you so so much my regards to
my family
ryan waverly and tyler and your wife and
and i'm looking forward to meeting in
person
and i'm looking forward to following
closely and regardless of what happens
thank you for all the amazing work that
you're doing around the world
at the end it's literally you know
saving lives and improving people's
lives
wherever you go so i think that's that's
what i'm leaving here with thank you
very much dave
thank you join me at
hardinforcongress.com
h-a-r-d-e-n for congress.com we're right
we're building the movement to return
decency back to congress
thank you michael you're all grown up
now i'm very proud of you
thank you very much take care
you